in the next few years I'm most excited
to see disruptive innovation reverse
innovation when I talk about innovation
I talk about finding new ways to do old
things so particularly with respect to
the underserved and poor households in
Nigeria in Africa finding new ways to do
the things that they've done in the past
that will make it easier for them make
it more economical for them make it
better for them to participate in the
economy one of the ways that we've done
that with innovation up until now is by
working and financing of mobile savings
and payments company which is made it
easier for people in far-flung areas
rural areas prairie urban areas of Lagos
and other cities in Nigeria to save and
to pay for basic goods and services I'm
excited to see how we can find other
innovation like that that will disrupt
and find new ways to do all things and
that we can import into the exports to
the developed countries so that it's not
just a case of innovation coming from
developed countries but also innovation
coming from developing countries